the cost of everything is up inflation
has surged to levels we haven't seen in
four decades
8.6 percent year over year
you have to go to 1982 to find a higher
number
with higher prices on food to gas to
rent inflation impacts everyone
whether you're watching tv or standing
on the checkout line signs of record
high inflation are unavoidable in the
last year food prices are up 10 new
vehicles 12 and a half and gasoline
almost 50 percent
in economics inflation is defined as
quote persistent substantial rise of
prices related to an increase in the
volume of money and resulting in the
loss of value of currency in other words
your snickers bar costs an extra 25
cents
so what's driving the rise of prices our
brook silva braga gets a crash course
jacob goldstein is a financial
journalist known for explaining
complicated economic concepts to
non-economists right on time hey man
good to see you thanks for doing this so
we pulled him away from his podcast
what's your problem to take a road trip
exploring america's problem with
inflation it's journalists and cars
getting expensive stuff i'm ready i'm
ready let's buy everything
everything it seems like is getting more
expensive a whopper with a medium fry
and an impossible whopper with a medium
fry
23.26 drive up please okay thank you
good thing i didn't order a coke huh
two of the biggest categories jumping in
price thank you food
and fuel
i mean
gas is incredibly expensive it's
extraordinary it's gone up so much so
fast and you know one of the things
about gas is you just see it right like
it's literally in your face you know
there's a great big sign and then you
start pumping and you watch the numbers
go up so it's like extra painful
and it's expensive because of the war in
ukraine largely right yeah i mean russia
invaded ukraine russia's a huge supplier
of oil you know people aren't buying as
much oil from russia so that's a big
part of it add to that another supply
problem refining capacity lost during
the pandemic hasn't fully recovered the
price of oil the price of gas is an
input into almost everything right you
make something in china you got to get
it to the u.s you got to buy fuel in a
really simple way when the price of gas
goes up it pushes up the price of
everything else but it's not just fuel
the supply of lots of things has
struggled to rebound after the pandemic
from microchips to potato chips but
groceries are another one yeah huge huge
and obviously really important right
like not something people can not buy at
morton williams supermarket in new york
city manager douglas mckinley told us
he's never had so much trouble placing
orders what's hard to stock it's across
the board almost every vendor has an
issue is there baby formula on the
shelves right now no we don't we haven't
been able to get them in just a year
eggs here have almost doubled and why
are they so much because of the bird flu
but of all the supply issues
contributing to inflation i mean i will
say 350 seems like a lot for a bag of
pretzels none are as important to
economists as the supply of workers
right now for every american looking for
a job there are two job openings so
unemployment is at this historic low now
right and sort of weirdly that's a big
part of the reason inflation is so high
it can be hard to grasp at first but low
unemployment is both good for
individuals and sometimes problematic
for the economy because it means
employers have to outbid each other for
the few available workers and what shops
like this what lots of businesses have
to do is raise wages right and the way
they can afford to raise wages is by
passing the cost on you by raising the
prices and so that's what's happening
across the economy right now
unemployment was low before the pandemic
2 but what's different now is the
combination of all those supply problems
and pumped up demand look the problem is
the economy overheated
it overheated in part because the
government didn't just inject money into
the economy at the start of the pandemic
but again last year there will be
fourteen hundred dollar checks approving
a record 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
while interest rates stayed at historic
lows in retrospect the government should
not have put so much money into the
economy at the time one of the few
people who warned that stimulus brought
inflation risks was former treasury
secretary larry summers so i just used
economics and said when you have too
much demand and not enough supply you
tend to get inflation unfortunately that
risk has come home
now summers has the ear of president
biden i was
talking to larry summers this morning
and offers a gloomy view of the road
ahead pointing out that every other time
unemployment has been this low and
inflation this high the result has been
recession i hope we can achieve the
proverbial soft landing but it would be
a first time if we did
to contain inflation he said we'll need
an unemployment rate above five percent
for several years an outcome that would
mean millions of americans out of work
it would likely be accomplished by
sucking money back out of the economy by
raising interest rates fed chair jerome
powell already announced a hike this
month by three quarters of a percentage
point summer says we need much more it's
not too late to bring the situation
under control but we're going to have to
accept some real pain and dislocation in
order to do it and we're not quite there
yet we're raising we're raising but i
think we're likely to have a ways to go
i think we're going to have to push
interest rates quite far up house for
sale yeah our road trip with goldstein
ended back in his brooklyn neighborhood
where the same type of home he bought
just last year
might not go for quite as much just now
interest rates are going up interest
rates for mortgages are going up a lot
so we expect that means house prices
will stop going up so much in some
places they might even go down
that should help cool inflation but
economists don't agree if we've turned
the corner quite yet has inflation
peaked i think inflation's
more likely to go down over the next
several months than it is to go up
but i'm not sure it's down forever i
think it's a mistake to assume that
we've seen the worst of inflation do you
assume we have not yet seen the worst my
rule in life is always to hope for the
best and plan for the worst
after two years of the pandemic war and
international strife that brought us
here uncertainty is one of the few
things we've gotten used to paying for
for cbs saturday morning brook silva
braga new york
we certainly have gotten used to
uncertainty yes we have right
really it's it's incredible what we've
been living with over the last two
decades but here's the news flash out of
that as well who knew there was a bird
flu
with the eggs
and apparently it's nationwide and it's
impacting wild birds as well as
domesticated ones so thank you for that
prices would have been up regardless but
put that on top put it on top what's
next what's next something will be next
i know you know that